[Música]
[Aplausos]
o pai serão agora na minha apresentação
vai partilhar convosco a minha história
e uma paixão que acredita ser a resposta
para uma construção sustentável
licenciado em arquitetura como sair no
trabalho ruim dentro da arquitetura
dentro do mercado tradicional e
contemporânea da construção em portugal
onde vai assistir à em função desta
indústria onde lóes normas e
certificações surgem em prol de uma tal
de sustentabilidade ser dos uma
quantidade de certificações e
principalmente um jogo no mercado
insatisfeita com esta situação e
consciente do impacto está em nível do
ambiente e principalmente dessas
exigências a nível da construção e da
vida útil do edifício e inicia uma busca
uma busca nas costas nas respostas que
procurava poder construir realmente é
aquilo que eu achava que era construção
sustentável
essa busca no roma a origem na cultura
chinesa o tal é essência do universo
origem todo o universo presente em todas
as coisas animadas e animadas que se
manifesta segundo duas formas de energia
e apostas mas ao mesmo tempo e
contemporâneas para alcançar um
equilíbrio das forças da natureza
ela manifesta segundo estas duas
energias que temos com certeza você já
conhece ninguém é que representa
é o céu o masculino e feminino
ninguém já o karma reflete o princípio
espiritual de causa e efeito ações do
indivíduo você é ter no futuro desse
livro em 1972
james walker conclui que terra além da
residência por diversas formas de vida é
também ela própria um grande serviço
isto deu origem à teoria de gaia
nessa teoria o centro que os organismos
interagem com suas com seus arredores e
inorgânicos
segundo um sistema complexo para manter
e perpetuar a vida no nosso planeta
agora estou a falar do triste conceitos
diferentes em culturas diferentes mas
que tudo e todos e deus no fundo acabam
por chegar a uma mesma conclusão
na natureza tudo está interligado
toda ação tem uma reação ea
sustentabilidade é isso mesmo
para isso temos que contemplar em um
conjunto variado de variantes
interdisciplinares ambientais sociais e
energéticas e econômicas
e foi em busca deste conceito que em
2003 uma ia lá encontrei a terra é terra
com material de construção
sinto que durante o meu percurso escolar
e mesmo com a arquiteta nunca imagina
essa terra e não nunca foi transmitido
este material com material possível
construção falava sem madeira notar um
alinhamento no ferro no jogo mas não na
terra
ela surge nos nossos dias encontrava
numa nova forma de projetar o nosso
futuro
mas encontrei também da terra um novo
portugal em portugal com o património
imenso de construção em terra haverá
exemplo disso
edifícios de grande qualidade
arquitetônica mas também poços que
e vai mesmo feito por blocos de terra
imersa em água seguiu então até os
nossos dias
muitos dos mais antigos dizem que têm
mais de 100 anos mas porque terra está
presente em todo o lado é nossa origem e
por isso vamos imaginar quando compramos
um terreno é que o quanto ficamos é a
área está é a superfície
o espaço que eu representa e talvez a
sua envolvente e o estado mais nossos
pés e seus disser que é isso vai tornar
o material da nossa constituição da
nossa casa
ora um evento na primeira fase difícil
na primeira camada temos a matéria
orgânica esta matéria atualizada para a
agricultura e para o tratamento da
paisagem o que é que eu faço
utilizo no jardim ou até mesmo na
cultura das minhas condições
logo abaixo tá em pedras na virilha e
terra
isto é era e sinti e argila e é com isso
que vou construir as minhas nos meus
edifícios mas para isso eu tenho que
vencer os seus constituintes em suas
características posso fazê-lo de uma
forma bastante mais simples no local
recorrendo aos meus sentidos mas é
necessário nos nossos dias
utilizamos uma moratória e com isso
terem xx chegarmos a conclusões que nos
permita inteira certeza que estamos a
responder às normas regulamentares da
construção dessa forma conseguimos
garantir uma construção de qualidade
só após esta este estudo e conhecimento
do material que temos com nós podemos
escolher essas tecnologias e partir para
a produção
a produção é feita com material local
e obviamente local é é vantagem utilizar
o material local e fazemos essa produção
nesse e indiretamente no qual estamos a
construir é que estamos a reduzir o
trânsito e transportes
tudo que está envolvido no transporte
deste material
vamos reduzir também as matérias em que
vão envolver a nossa com são matérias
primas linda
vamos produzir também vamos reduzir
também autoriza por exemplo a utilização
de rocks e pinturas porque isso pode ser
utilizar esse material nós podemos
utilizar para aparelhos até para
culturas mas a mãe para fazer o roubo
das nossas habitações estão alimentos
ele é ecológico 100% ecológico e isto só
para vocês terem uma noção
em portugal temos uma produção de 7,5
milhões toneladas da ravt constituição e
munição
a nível mundial isto representa 40% da
produção de resíduos
nós vemos 92 dos quais de demolição e 8
constituição quando recorremos à terra
em si não acontece porque tá reciclável
da inglaterra e volta à terra e
utilizava porque eu posso construir do
lille e com o mesmo material voltar a
construir isso acontecia muitas vezes as
cidades aqui em portugal em que os pais
davam aos filhos para sua própria
habitação sem qualquer problema porque
os próprios viviam os meus filhos podem
deitar abaixo a esta casa e construir
uma nova
respeitando e respondendo às
necessidades que está em ela é também
nosso 3º pel primeiro pouco nos portela
protege afinal é o nosso brio
apresenta seus exemplos 28 e edson
ateliês de pintura e ao mesmo tempo
providências e os seus proprietários
escolheram este material para tirar
partido das suas características
ela expirar ela vai o ar umidade do
ambiente reduzir os tóxicos presentes
nessas ambiente iluminar odores e também
regular a temperatura interna da
habitação escrita nos permite nos ter um
ambiente novo e durável
neste caso temos a cidadã santana
esta cidade tem mais de 2.500 anos é
feita em casas é feita em casas é ele e
do rio são quase como arranha céus
porque chegam a ter 14 metros de altura
mas ela contempla também a nível social
é fácil construir porque pois é possível
a autoconstrução este é um exemplo da de
uma comunidade se reúne para construir é
casa do do novo habitar em ter por cento
acumulada é que nós conseguimos ver as
diferentes faixas etárias podem estar
envolvidas nesta construção
o prevê ea emoção que surge do contato
com este material mas também pra ele eu
conseguimos construir na atualidade com
este com esta matéria com o terra e
citamos mão de obra especializada quando
eu falo mandava especializada
automaticamente estou a falar de uma
formação especializada que deve
contemplar todos os fios entre menos
desde arquitetos engenheiros aos
construtores que temos alguns exemplos
do adquirente temos a formação de
estagiários de arquitetura do cabimento
que vão sentir não só aprender o que é
construir mas senti na pele o que
significa trabalhar neste material e
esforço que procurar os incitam de fazer
para trabalhar do lado esquerdo é um
exemplo
a gente foi na índia e e e preto quando
vantagem que tiramos a cofragem é
técnica da taipa a 40 por cento dos 4
quando afirma a dona da obra pois vai
ter uma casa de chocolate que realmente
é isso que parece é contemporâneo
permite-nos ter linguagem modernas dias
do moderno ao tradicional adversário e
que temos várias hipóteses várias formas
de trabalhar
o material desde que estas técnicas a ao
formato
temos também ela também estrutural
possível fazer construções autoportantes
e por isso podemos fazer paredes
autoportantes pilares arx agora dizia
ter culpa os ela dos o consumo
energético do edifício
isso porque tem ótimo comportamento é
graças à sua inércia diferente e ainda
nos permite fazer era so fóruns porque é
a prova de fogo depois tudo isto eu
penso que posso afirmar que vocês
concordam comigo que a terra está
disponível para todos nós e qualquer um
de nós
após construir onde quiser em sua casa
em terra elas fundo as necessidades de
uma sociedade contemporânea dentro do
seu contexto econômico e vi e e
respondendo também há a ambiente e
restante respeitando o meio ambiente
por isso meu desafio e e que espero é
que vossa próxima casa seja em terra
namastê
[Aplausos]